[Música]
momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en France 24 soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en España porque
una bebé de 13 meses recibió un
trasplante de intestino que se considera
histórico por la técnica utilizada el
intestino Es un órgano que hasta la
década de 1990 no era ampliamente
considerado para trasplante por las
altas probabilidades de rechazo o de
infección pese a las investigaciones e
intentos de los últimos 30 años solo
hasta ahora este procedimiento fue
exitoso y se logró porque el intestino
donado por un paciente fallecido se
preservó con un sistema de oxigenación
por membrana extra corpórea que en otras
palabras permite el flujo de sangre
oxigenada por el órgano la receptora
eczema y este era su padecimiento Emma
presentaba una enfermedad que se llama
fracaso intestinal o fallo intestinal
eso qué significa significa que por un
problema por una enfermedad su intestino
no es capaz de absorber la energía los
alimentos que necesita para crecer y
vivir normalmente eso significa que en
los primeros meses de vida tuvo que ser
intervenida por diferentes problemas y
dado que su intestino no es capaz de
mantener esta este normal crecimiento
pues necesita recibir la alimentación
por medio de la vía intravenosa
nutrición parenteral tras tres años de
investigaciones los médicos del hospital
de la paz en Madrid que es pionero en el
área de trasplantes lograron la
viabilidad de la operación y la
viabilidad de un intestino donado en las
historia es decir cuando se determina la
muerte porque ya no hay función cardíaca
ni respiratoria espontánea cabe Resaltar
que Emma por su condición también
recibió hígado estómago páncreas y vaso
en la misma intervención creo que es
importante insistir como directora de la
ont en lo que representa este trasplante
lo que ha representado para Emma pero lo
que va a representar este importante
para muchos niños en España y en otros
países del mundo porque realmente
estamos hablando de un hito es el primer
trasplante intestinal de donantes de
donante en las historias que se efectúa
en España y en el mundo realmente
estamos hablando de una intervención
absolutamente pionera las autoridades
españolas estiman que un 30% de los
pacientes que requieren un trasplante de
intestino fallecen en la lista de espera
algo que puede cambiar
significativamente con Esta técnica que
permite que el órgano no solo un
intestino de un donante muerto se
mantenga correctamente oxigenado hasta
que se realice la intervención
vamos ahora a Chile porque en el Golfo
de corcovado fue instalada la primera
olla inteligente que busca ayudar a
ballenas que estén en peligro de chocar
con barcos cuando migran desde la
antártida hasta el Ecuador la boya hace
parte de bluebout iniciative una
propuesta que tiene como objetivo crear
un sistema de alerta temprana que avise
a los barcos sobre la presencia de
ballenas para evitar colisiones las
señales emitidas son recibidas por la
armada chilena que alerta a las
embarcaciones sobre la presencia de
estos cetáceos uno de los lugares en el
mundo más rico en flora y fauna Marina
en este lugar justamente se reúnen la
mayor cantidad de ballenas azules
Durante los meses de verano de todo el
hemisferio sur para alimentarse a ella
la siguen la ballena franca la ballena 6
todas ellas en peligro de extinción
además de otras especies endémicas como
puede ser el delfín chileno y también
una gran cantidad de aves esta zona Por
tanto se vuelve única en biodiversidad
en Pero además debido a su geografía a
su relieve está llena de canales de
fiordos de Islas lo que hace que
finalmente todo lo que es el transporte
debe hacerse mucho más formar que por
tierra estas boyas marinas inteligentes
fueron desarrolladas por la universidad
politécnica de Cataluña y están
equipadas con hidrófonos una especie de
micrófonos acuáticos y otros sensores de
temperatura pH salinidad nutrientes y
oxígeno disuelto que sirven para
registrar variaciones en el agua estos
instrumentos permiten desarrollar
estudios sobre el impacto del cambio
climático en la biodiversidad Marina en
la capacidad que tenemos de escuchar el
mar y no solamente escucharlo entender
sus mensajes no a nivel filosófico que
realmente científico tecnológico somos
capaces de descifrar los diferentes
Fuentes acústicas que se producen dentro
del agua combinarlas en un paisaje no no
coherente alertar de unos efectos
negativos y actividades humanas o del
cambio climático para poder actuar
investigar el caso de que Obviamente
identifiquemos que el problema es para
darlo la iniciativa planea instalar
hasta seis boyas en este sector y es el
resultado de casi una década de estudios
y desarrollos recordemos que cada gran
ballena puede capturar o secuestrar 33
toneladas de CO2 en promedio Lo que
equivale a 33.000 kilogramos esta
capacidad es clave para mitigar el
impacto de la acidificación de los
océanos por la continua absorción de gas
carbónico
finalizamos en Australia con estos
drones polinizadores que están diseñados
para ayudar en este proceso en lugares
cerrados como invernaderos donde la
presencia de abejas no siempre es óptima
se trata de un proyecto de la
Universidad de Western Sydney con drones
desarrollados en Singapur la
polinización Es una herramienta de
gestión clave que los agricultores que
están bajo cultivos de protección tienen
que manejar y esta investigación Está
tratando de permitirles hacerlo de
manera más efectiva y reducir sus costos
de insumos ya previamente se habían
realizado pruebas en Londres y según los
responsables de esa iniciativa los
drones permitieron una mejora anual del
50%, frente a la polinización con
abejorros en Australia la importación de
abejorros está prohibida por lo que gran
parte de los cultivos como los de fresas
o tomates se polinizan manualmente algo
que según expertos toma mucho más tiempo
y es más complejo
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con nosotros en francés 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]